ce soir marc parent qui est le pdg de
cae qui était aux côtés du ministre de
la santé christian dubé aujourd'hui on
soit monsieur parent bonsoir ses clients
alors c'est quoi le rôle de cae dans
l'opération vaccination qui est
entrepris en entreprise et je décline
ici on est ici à prime abord écoute le
savez sûrement nous devons aussi curité
et à la base tout ce qu'on fait on fait
dans l'aviation au final secteur de la
défense puis moins connus on le fait
dans le secteur de la santé est si ce
qu'ils ont concevoir des respirateurs
pendant la pandémie même si notre
secteur d'aviation été grandement
affectée
on s'était puisqu'ils ont en effet des
applications pour faire de la création
pour entraîner les gens pour l mythril
de l'axé et maintenant on se tourne à
vacciner gens regroupés les entreprises
en partenariat avec le gouvernement et
donc soyons concret ça ressemble à quoi
un pôle de vaccination dans une
entreprise comme cae par exemple et on
doute on voit des exemples parfaits
parce que nous en ce moment on est entré
dans un grande reconstruction de
certains de nos secteurs dans l' usine
pour vraiment se transformer en centre
de vaccination et pour compléter et ça
ça va être deux semaines ça va
ressembler très étroitement à ce convoi
d'un centre de vaccination du secteur
public
oui et est ce qu on comprend que vous
allez fournir les employés pour la
vaccination et toutes les entreprises
qui s'inscrivent fournissent les
employés qui vont vacciner les autres
employés oui on fournit le personnel ont
tourné des installations tout est fait
gratuitement par toutes les entreprises
qui se joignent à départ est ce que je
peux vous dire que depuis qu'on est
ouvert plus je lance le message
aujourd'hui le site web ex nation
entreprises point cornes ont chois
littéralement des centaines de bandes de
demandes d'entreprises pour dire qu'ils
veulent contribuer il le dire comment
est votre contribue donc ça va se passer
et puis on va accélérer la vaccination
c'est notre but il ya 750 entreprises
qui ont levé la main auprès de la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec
est ce que toutes ces entreprises se
qualifie pour avoir des pôles de
vaccination ou pour se regrouper autour
d'un pôle de vaccination que je vous
dise qu'on ne peut pas besoin d'abord
des centaines de pots de vaccination on
a besoin de 20 à 50 pourquoi respecter
l'engagement qu'on doit donner au
gouvernement un peu sur paris le che
dubé à pouvoir accéder jusqu'à 500 1000
québécois et québécoises pendant des
parcs on perd c'est donc des entreprises
que ça rejoint au pot de vexations % des
ressources et n'importe qu'elle est et
bienvenue dans deux semaines trois
semaines quatre semaines au mois de mai
les pots de vaccination seront en place
un employé de cae qui dit à betting
impôts de vaccination pourquoi il s'est
inscrit à votre peau de vaccination
pourquoi il ne s'inscrit pas ailleurs
dans le système est ce que ça va aller
plus vite pour employés de cae de se
faire vacciner chez ces halles de prime
abord que je vous dise qui est très
important c'est que l'effort se fait
dans le respect absolu
dès lors deux priorités définies par le
gouvernement
donc pas question de personne que ce
soit dans l'entreprise au doit passer
devant la file doux on va vacciner en
entreprise nos employés et leurs
familles et la communauté en général en
même temps selon l'ordre de priorité du
gouvernement
ok donc on garde l'ordre de priorité en
ce moment c'est 65 ans et plus si vous
aviez un pot de vaccination en ce moment
ce serait 65 ans et plus effectivement
parfait on parle de 10000 à 25000
personnes dans chacun des poses de
vaccination de 10 à 15 semaines comment
on va s'assurer que les objectifs seront
atteints
moi je suis très confiant que les autres
jeux suivants et atteint jusque qu'est
ce que vous avez dit salah 750
entreprises maintenant qu'ils veulent
venir d'où porter l'aide pour le faire
arriver on est des plans très détaillé
brigitte rey confirme va l'atteindre
puis encore une fois les faire vacciner
tous les québécois et les élus québécois
le plus rapidement possible de concert
avec le secteur public les pharmacies
ensemble
ça vous tient à coeur de toute évidence
de toute façon vous avez plusieurs
reprises depuis un an intervenir sur le
sur le plan de la coved je vous de vous
demander à vous monsieur parent est ce
que vous vous êtes d'avis que pour
revenir dans un bureau pour revenir au
travail il faut être vaccinés
écoutez nous ce qu'on veut faire ses
lacets les gens leur donner le poster
d'accès tout le monde qui peut être
vaccinées doivent pas les gens vont
faire leur choix eux mêmes
moi je montais revacciner je peux vous
dire je vais encourager les gens à
vacciner on va créer la possibilité de
tout le monde espère vacciner
après ça les gens pour qu'ils passent
leur choix mais vous comme employeur
vous pouvez pas dire à vos employés
obligatoirement vacciner pour revenir au
travail
non non plus pas pu rentrer répond ok
bon ben voilà l'opération est lancée
les inscriptions vont se faire les
pauses seront annoncées au mois d'avril
bonne chance cette importance qui se
passe merci beaucoup monsieur par un
merci monsieur peillon